long lines to get a kofi 19 vaccine are
a thing of the past now it's a struggle
to get people on board with boosters
with just over half of eligible
canadians having received their third
dose there's no question about it
between the second shot and the third
one that's where the rubber hits the
road research suggests kovid's latest
omicron mutations ba 4 and 5 are four
times more resistant to vaccine
antibodies compared to their predecessor
ba2 and while pharmaceutical companies
such as moderna and pfizer are working
on formulas to target those strains
experts still encourage getting a third
shot with the current mrna vaccine the
main benefit is just from boosting so
boosting jacks up the antibodies which
protects the against all of the variants
including ba5 the federal government
recommends a booster nine months post
your last shot but it isn't a hard and
fast rule some provinces now say five
months is long enough and if you are
young and healthy and are hoping for a
fourth dose experts say the best defense
is one that is timed you want your
highest protection from the vaccine
which is within the first few months
after you get a dose
to be at a time when virus is highest
over the age of 50 living in long-term
care or immunocompromised doctors
suggest booking a booster now
and if you've just had covid three
months is how long you should wait to
get another shot but it doesn't mean
you're in the clear to get infected with
ba1 you're well protected against ba1
except we don't have any ba1 anymore
right now you have to worry about ba-5
canadian scientists are tracking even
newer strains and while they can't be
certain what covett has in store
vaccines they say are likely to play a
role in our protection plan every year
jamie morocco global news toronto